100 sterne einfach so verschwunden und
das innerhalb eines kurzen zeitraums von
nur wenigen jahrzehnten fachleute
rätseln jetzt ob außerirdische
zivilisation für dieses mysteriöse
verschwinden verantwortlich sind klicks
und science fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktivierte glocke nur dann und
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
das war wirklich enorm viel arbeit rund
600 millionen himmelsobjekte hatte das
internationale forschungsteam um die
astrophysikerin wert riss villarroel ins
visier genommen und mit einem katalog
des pan stars also dem panoramic survey
telescope and rapid response system
verglichen
dabei fiel etwas ungewöhnliches auf in
dem alten sternen katalog spürten die
fachleute 150 tausend objekte auf für
die es in ihrem aktuellen himmels atlas
keine entsprechung gab diese mysteriösen
anomalien interessierten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
natürlich sehr und so schauten sie sich
insgesamt 24.000 objekte davon noch
etwas genauer an
das ergebnis 100 zitat besonders
interessante quellen im klartext heißt
das also bei dem vergleich mit den
sternen aufnahmen aus den 50er jahren
fielen 100 objekte ins auge die in
dieser kurzen zeit einfach von der
bildfläche
oder besser gesagt vom himmel
verschwunden sind
doch wie kann das sein das
forschungsteam selbst schließt
tatsächlich nicht aus dass außerirdische
zivilisation für das mysteriöse
verschwinden dieser 100 sterne
verantwortlich sein könnten dazu
schreibt das autorenteam in der
aktuellen studien das zitat
beobachtungen wie diese eine
herausforderung für die astrophysik
darstellen handelt es sich bei den 100
fehlenden objekten möglicherweise um
hinweise auf die sogenannten weißen
sphären dabei handelt es sich um
theoretisch beschriebene strukturen wohl
kugeln die einen stern umhüllen und so
dessen gesamte energie absorbieren
falls man solch einen tysons wäre
aufspüren könnte wäre dass tatsächlich
ein beweis für außerirdisches leben das
intelligent und hoch entwickelt ist der
us astrophysiker denn huber von der
university of chicago ein sehr seriöser
und kompetenter wissenschaftler hatte
diese hohlkugeln in einem online aufsatz
in betracht gezogen wie hoch
entwickeltes leben in der zukunft die
expansion des universums überstehen
könnte darüber haben welche bei
kriegstagen science fiction ja
ausführlich berichtet mit solch einer
dyson sphäre die einen stern komplett
umschließt und so seine ganze energie
absorbiert oder umlenkt ließen sich
planetensysteme beschleunigen somit
könnte man der ausdehnung des alls
entgehen und in die andere richtung
fliegen
doch zurück zu den 100 verschwunden
sternen das internationale
forschungsteam stieß also nicht aus dass
außerirdische zivilisation dahinter
stecken doch zitat klare hinweise auf
außerirdisches leben gibt es nach
angaben der fachleute bislang auch noch
nicht dennoch räumten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
diesem außerirdischen erklärungsansatz
enorm viel raum in ihrer studie ein
doch es gibt weitere spannende
erklärungsmöglichkeiten handelt es sich
etwa um ein ganz neues bislang
unbekanntes astrophysikalische phänomen
bisher ging man davon aus dass sterbende
sterne verschiedenen zustände aufweisen
und sich dann letztendlich zu einem
weißen zwerg stern entwickeln aber auch
eine plötzliche explosion in einer
hellen supernova ist möglich denkbar ist
es dass solch eine supernova gescheitert
ist und genau das plötzliche
verschwinden der sterne erklärt
vorstellbar ist dann nämlich dass ein
stern direkt in ein schwarzes loch
zusammengefallen ist als ziemlich
wahrscheinlich bewerten fachleute den
möglichen erklärungsansatz dass es sich
um veränderliche sterne handelt die in
den vergangenen 70 jahren an helligkeit
verloren haben dies würde dazu führen
dass man sie heute nicht mehr
detektieren kann möglicherweise könnte
sich aber auch um einen großen zufall
handeln dass diese sterne genau vor 70
jahren so hell waren dass sie sich
detektieren ließen denkbar ist es
demnach dass es sich um sogenannte rote
m sterne handelt die immer mal wieder
helligkeit ausbrüche zeigen ihre
oberfläche ist etwa 4000 grad warm und
damit vergleichsweise kühl und ihr
rötliches licht ist er schwach die
bilder von damals waren vor allem im
roten licht sensibel und möglicherweise
waren diese im sterne damals gerade hell
genug um abgerichtet zu werden zudem
zieht das forschungsziel zwei weitere
lösungsvorschläge in betracht zum einen
könnte es sich um
eine bildfehler handeln und zum anderen
könnte sich auch um braune oder rote
zwerge handelt diese schwach leuchtende
objekte könnten in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten ihre positionen verändert
haben um das mysteriöse verschwinden
diese einrad objekte ein für alle mal zu
klären sind jedenfalls noch weitere
analysen notwendig und genau das soll
das projekt vanishing empfing sources
thüringer century of nations kurt vasco
jetzt auch tun so sollen hinweise darauf
gefunden werden wie sich sterne in
extrem schnellen phasen entwickeln denn
genau das ist extrem schwierig zu
beobachten spannend ist auch die frage
ob bestimmte himmelsregion besonders
viele verschwindende sterne beherbergen
wann sehen wir eine supernova mit bloßen
auge am himmel anklicken anschauen und
neugier zum abonnieren hammer kanal
feiert bald sein einjähriges also
unbedingt abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran